foreign
[Music]
won re-election with an even higher
share of the popular vote than he got
four years ago that gives him the same
comfortable majority of 158 seats in the
300-seat parliament he promised to use
it to pull Greece out of the depression
it's been in since the 2009 Global
financial crisis
the main thing we achieved in this
election was to close once and for all
the Vicious Cycle of division and
toxicity that started a decade ago
tomorrow we roll up our sleeves and
start working hard
mitsotaki's first term was consumed by a
series of crises the covid-19 pandemic a
crisis with turkey in the summer of 2020
and the war in Ukraine altogether they
cost the Greek State 66 billion euros in
Lost tax revenue and subsidies but they
also did two things they convinced the
Greeks that mitsotagis is a very
competent manager capable of handling
difficult situations and they seem to
have convinced most Greeks that he
deserves a second chance to implement
his economic reform program one
businessman said he especially liked new
democracy's efforts to make Greece more
efficient
[Music]
it's the party that does the least harm
this is a government that has tried to
do some things that gets stuck sometimes
because Greece has a deep State that's
difficult to fix but at least it tries
to get some things done things I
appreciated most were e-government and
the fact that they got pensions out to
people quickly
it's new democracy's second election win
in Five Weeks by Going to the Country
again the party triggered a law changing
the voting system to award 50 extra
seats to the largest party making stable
governments easier to form
two right-wing nationalist parties the
Spartans and Nikki picked up eight and a
half percent of the vote and will enter
Parliament for the first time that's
partly the result of new democracy's
main opposition the left-wing series of
party shedding half its followers
creating a scattering of small parties
some of which may be short-lived new
democracy promised growth and new jobs
that will keep young people from leaving
the country it's likely to wonder why
many voters didn't believe that pledge
mitsotaki's message of rolling up
sleeves is aimed at convincing them John
saropoulos Al Jazeera Athens